hey guys where we going we're gonna go
and do some tasks we all want you to the
costume store because we're having a
costume party that's not actually
supposed to be a dress-up party but then
I was like oh I'm gonna dress up I still
want to be our peanut butter and jelly
Jen who if we can't find that no I'm not
wearing it we need to chat about
portrait mode on the iPhone 7 plus it
looks incredible look at these great
shots which I just took with me look at
this one especially I said ok I'm gonna
laugh really really hard don't take the
shot I think I'm definitely James going
to what are these they're like french
fries I just got the greatest shoes ever
oh my god I tried to get Jenna to go to
pause the zoo King Quinn they're gonna
make me feel something I think that's
what I like to go to feel the bags for
the little LEGO Minifigures do you think
he sees us yet no not at all nothing can
stop me I'm although I am I don't get it
is this a joke huzzah we just got home
from shopping and a box has arrived you
will see it here let's switch to the
good cam and we're gonna do the unboxing
man you excited for the GoPro Karma
let's open this up it's a big case of
thing oh my goodness is this heavy this
is no backpack this is a freaking spilt
cake I will say this will definitely
protect you if you're in a plane crash
this thing big this is definitely not
something that you can put in your purse
so this is one of the things that I'm
pretty excited about because you can
just take off the gimbal here and attach
it to this little writing all the steady
stick it's much bigger than I thought
but this looks really good I mean I love
this design of this controller I just
feel like it's a little bit bulky here's
our propellers oh they look good real
real slick wait yeah they give you two
extras I will say it's packaged very
nice this is an extremely protective
case so all in all everything that came
with it is the controller propellers the
drone itself here's our charging cables
one time I decide to use a black
able to unbox something everything's
black let's put these repellers on the
screws are color coordinated with the
propellers just screw them on cuz just
the Mavic is this big Oh like I'll go
gotta enjoy a nice comparison over the
valley good thing you'll break it will
replace it covered for two years hmm
what if I accidentally lose it and it
flies off into oblivion so here it is
all spread out so this is like Matt look
at this I have four Mavic batteries in
here the drone the controller a car
charger and all of the chargers I have
everything in here like this oops you
have been wrong
yes like this is crazy car charger drone
charger the drone oh my god the control
a battery the controller another battery
another battery there's four batteries
isn't that nuts so here's the thing DJI
has been in the drone business for a lot
longer than GoPro and I feel like GoPro
is definitely catering towards the
sports market and people that already
have the GoPro can this will also work
with a GoPro Hero 4 the clearly if
you're gonna get it you should probably
just get the GoPro Hero 5 and get the
whole set and get everything together
but man like this Matic is so so great
and I've been using it for so long but
it just it can't even I just it's gonna
be so hard for me to like fall in love
with this
the Karma I mean like look at this size
compared like it doesn't freaking
compare like what is Mac just could you
get over him look at this that's it it's
unbeliev I know and like fold it up one
of the cool things though you can do on
the karma is you're able to these don't
even fold up either oh man this isn't an
official unboxing this is just a vlog
unboxing so don't mind everything is all
over the place it's at the bottom here
this all flips out just like so I guess
I'll set it up the screen looks good
though this looks nice one of the cool
things that they showed in their press
announcement was that you're able to fly
with the controller and there's also a
companion app so saying that was out
with me he could control the camera so
that is pretty awesome
looks like the battery is dead so I
can't do anything right now
Lisa's charges with the USB see so
they're consistent thank you so much if
you guys can see it but here in the
gimbal they have this plugs into both
the HDMI and the USB seaboards
also to take this out put it in here and
charge both of these things hi guys so
we're doing party prep today this is the
gimbal basically that is of the drone so
I took it off and you put it on I mean
we're calling it the steady stick that's
the official term here but Justine is
calling it general so I believe you got
on a steady stick before - right yeah
that was it
I still haven't even been able to fly
the drone yet look Betty you're over I
have to do an update though because I
don't think it's responding the way that
it should I haven't yet updated the
camera here's all the different modes
and it's great as you can actually just
control it from your hand here so you
don't have to actually touch the GoPro
last night we went somewhere and was
about an hour away and this was not
charged and I charged it fully off of
one of the large movies I've got my
recipe
[Music]
sangria do we have any more I love this
Lucas let's get it on that
Oh God swim everywhere a bad idea okay
yeah cool can you guys take a peek and
see what you can see do you see it the
snapchat filter I wish I knew who made
this I have to find them because it's my
favorite thing ever
candy I can't believe it
it's a great shot what are we watching
Jen mom puppies all day I'm gonna stream
sleep that a squirrel problem the
problem is the squirrels have parasites
and my dog keeps eating the parasite
compress it poo of the squirrels so I
had to get a vacuum so that I can vacuum
my lawn finally time for this go home
take flight controller there's an update
I need to connect the camera the drone
the stabilizer
why are you red what are you doing what
are you doing update online drone
controller um install so I have to
update it separately so I to take it out
of here for more updates make the camera
capture oh my goodness tivity cool
everything's working now let's update
this update updating updating updating I
really want to get this girl
Wow
I might eat it I gotta get replacement
lanes on like I just
oh my god
[Music]
[Music]
I will be doing a follow-up video if I
can get some replacement blades but
which is so very strange they only give
you two replacement ones and what if you
have a catastrophe your first flight
like what are you supposed to do you
clearly can't replace two blades when
there's four of them crafts go bro come
on guys two more blades is something I
think that's fair
give the people four blades I'm not like
I'm not upset about it because I'm going
to try to fix it and then I'm gonna do
I'm gonna take it out and probably fly
it somewhere else but the problem really
with it is only goals 0.5 miles which is
not very far so I don't know we're gonna
see what happens I'll get it fixed and I
know and to be fair I bought this they
did not send me this this is not
sponsored video clearly I don't think um
it's obviously not sponsored we're
putting on our costumes um me and Jenna
decided to be peanut butter and jelly we
also made peanut butter and jelly for
the party and Edie is Adam who are you
I'm a shy guy we're this oh good it's so
great I mean these little stitches it's
adjustable what you made this oh yeah I
mean last year but then no one ever got
to see it I think you showed me like a
really quick little picture of it whoa
you're the UH the Scarecrow in the
Arkham Asylum gay yes how he's like real
stitched up and everything that's what I
was kind of going for so I wanted like
this to look like it was like it looks
good whatever just in case anybody asks
me what I am Mady was Terry are you wow
you're like a portal no oh God you guys
gonna carry a small peanut butter and
jelly sandwich so people understand the
rule we have to be a little jealous I'm
out I'm gonna make them do we look like
peanut butter well we look stupid I
can't believe this cost $60 you look
like some kind of sandwich it's like
mustard uh
not good do you think you're ready very
content
are you making a movie you are that's a
video her you're putting our breads
together doesn't like that worried my
peanut barrel and I wasn't ready for
that jelly is oh he loves you look at
that big pile of whipped cream on top oh
my god
yeah it's okay yeah that's a good boy
you're very good Jetta we'll get you a
treat okay okay this is what our world
has come to camera damn wrong dog
costume Justine you are clinically
losing you're mocking Maddie you look
handsome I think you did your mom stupid
head out of the way we'll show us your
costume
very perfect oh you're so perfect
looking to me like what are we doing a
vlog ripped us off that it was such a
good little boy but I'm just gonna put
on a little handkerchief for him clearly
the costume thing is not something he's
into can you believe it
I can't it looks really good better than
I expected so the creator of this image
please find me I need to find you I
recreated an illustrator so that she'd
be able to print it onto the cake
directly it looks so funny nice color I
also got pitar and Lamar birthday cakes
because never our things are on October
I've been there oh my god no they're
right there well I put it away but to be
fair I didn't know the cakes right there
it's okay
wait till I put rice so that's my way I
don't know who is ketchup anymore let's
fight about it we also have a special
surprise so gentlemen our peanut butter
and jelly clearly gentle made peanut
butter and jelly Spooky's i'm not even
my god they look great they look okay
yes you guys did a great job
how are you oh yeah you've seen it it's
like you're a miner now I am a ex
pioneers I've been using vine more this
past week then the entire time oh I
think I think maybe they did this as a
prank
so more usage now I think this might
have realized vine okay so you guys have
probably seen Josh all over the Internet
because every year he makes these
incredible crazy amazing Halloween
costumes so are you ready huh are you
ready yeah I guess yokka service to the
test
tyonne napkin around your neck Cherie
and we will do the rest
it's all know anyone else Belle you guys
are so creative it hurts I'm just a
whiner
how long do you take to make so my
assistant Lisa builds them and it's
really labor-intensive because this is
all like sort of custom made from
scratch so yeah it was a like what's
multiple months of like of like trial
and error but like actual time is like
we I am for Halloween you're what a
washed-up Call of Duty Pro
and you're supposed to be something that
you're not I'm sorry that was the best
part 2016 you got to keep it in the
video that was incredible it's amazing
it's all good I should know because
smart people in your comments will be
like oh but Ashley should be the feather
duster but that that's her name if you
guys you guys remember from the movie
like movie ours like home oh look it's
like with the butt so yeah we want like
I thought that would be cool but it's
really hard to dress as a feather duster
and she prefer to be in a princess
obviously so but like so Ashley tries to
ship Lumiere and Belle and weird because
they're actually like with other people
great yeah but uh that's that's her idea
I actually did see a lot of those
comments on Instagram like what was your
but which is true no I mean a jacket
like when we are dust gate the feather
dusters so it so I guess in this costume
were just friends well I will link you
guys the video because the creation of
it like I saw her making it and it was
so so good like she did such a great job
yeah it's crazy just all these like
little things like this is all like
modeling clay and then this fabric she
like sewed and it's like stuffed with a
stuffing it's pretty I was like creeping
like accurate like it's incredible thank
you
yeah no well congratulations like I get
me she probably was already starting on
next year's well yeah we're talking
about it sure sure yeah it's like
actually I'm gonna start like June it
was like really crunch this yeah yeah so
yeah it's mounting pressure over here so
good congratulations high five yep Matt
do you like my costume British yeah I
basically stole your costume out of the
closet okay this is incredible
do a little dance or something it's all
good
well it's you
how was it good night hey what's
happening kid not sure well it was it
look I don't sit down to the steering
oh it just looks weird not as good so we
got some surprise birthday cakes for
Qatar and Lamar and when I went there
they're like oh they twins because
they're like smash cakes that you're
supposed to get like for kids I was like
oh no they're not come on twins they're
I'm just it's so fuel you can smash them
guys so what is it like you gotta get in
there right oh this is literally the
story of my life this is actually really
correct it's finally time no it's time
to be spooky okay take a look it is
really cloudy wonder what it is very
creamy very vanilla II very good II okay
yes
so just finishing editing this vlog and
realized I did not end the video and
Maddy is growling at me because I've
been editing videos all day wanted what
do you want I just show you this quick
clip of Maddy running around the house
trying to hide his bone it's so funny to
me why are we gonna put the bone where
should we put it we gotta hide it
somewhere oh gosh
what are we gonna do with it we have to
put it somewhere because someone's gonna
find it you gotta put it somewhere else
Maddy look I can just go like this you
can't do that you got to put it
somewhere else
Oh oh gosh now I've stolen the bone
someone's gonna get it
hurry hurry this is important go let's
go
is your bone not even important to you
anyway thanks for watching I also would
like to update you that I ordered for
no.6 I ordered six propellers for the
GoPro car bus so hopefully I will be
able to take it into some wide-open
spaces
Maddi wide open speed units honest I
think it's by the Dixie Chicks Alexa
play wide open spaces but open space
is Maddy we need wide open spaces for
gopher karma room to make big mistakes
that's basically this couldn't be any
better
Alexa stop playing okay see you guys
later bye how do they do it why do all
the photos look good it's a lie
everything's a lie the Internet is a lie
everything you see is not real I'm not
even here right now this is not real
then I'm gonna just sprinkle some of
these things on it
that looks so nice very spooky